war mein ganzes Make-up vielleicht ein
Fehler ja
maybe was ist das das sorry aber das
können die doch nicht einfach so droppen
denn dieser Adventskalender hier bringt
mich jedes Jahr aufs neue zum weinen
aber ich muss ihn jedes Jahr Auspacken
das hat hier mittlerweile
Tradition
ja interesting optisch ist er dieses
Jahr ja er sieht auch cute aus die
letzten Jahre hat er mir ein bisschen
gefallen so das war's mit dem Video bis
dann hallo ist das hier der absban heute
packen wir den adventssom
Adventskalender aus das ist ein
nachhaltiger Adventskalender mit vielen
Startups und vier spenden wenn man
diesen Kalender kauft hat man eigentlich
schon was gutes getan ich habe den schon
persönlich verschenkt weil ich das
einfach immer toll finde was für eine
Auswahl hier drin ist und die die den
herstellen wo seid ihr die sehen ja auch
nett aus ne und sie haben sogar Katzen
es ist so flaschig ich werde wahnsinnig
und bevor ich noch zu oft adventsum sage
oder wie aesome adventsor ist dieses
Video ist nicht gesponsert ich habe aber
diesen Kalender früher zugeschickt
bekommen und jetzt alle dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert aber ich habe den
Kalender früher zugeschickt gekriegt
mittlerweile habe ich hier ja eine große
Auswahl an Kalendern von denen ich mich
bedienen kann weil jetzt mittlerweile
liefern wirklich die meisten ihre
Kalender ich habe das Gefühl meine
Auswahl wird davon manipuliert dass ich
immer Bock auf Snacks habe und hier sind
hoffentlich wieder Snacks
drin der Kalender kommt immer in so
einer runden und hat ein sehr starken
Duft oh da muss irgendwas drin sein was
sehr doll riecht das sind auch schon
drei Türchen wie war das denn bei denen
nee komplett durcheinander ich guck mal
ganz kurz was der kostet
129 € aber Leute aus den letzten Jahren
haben wir gelernt hier kriegt man was
für sein Geld und was das genau ist
erfahren wir jetzt in Türchen Nummer ein
herrlich das coole hierbei ist die sind
wirklich handverpackt und man hat das
Gefühl jemand der einen liebt hat sich
Mühe gegeben na seht ihr mal mein Po
Fach ist voll dass ich mal den
duschbrocken Adventskalender
ausprobieren soll ich habe noch nie von
duschbrocken gehört und hier ist ein
duschbrocken das ist auch glaube ich das
Ding was so doll riecht oh es riecht
aber es riecht gut das riecht nach
Vanille wir wünschen dir eine schöne
Weihnachtszeit Mensch und ein
duschbrocken Gutschein grau ist jetzt
nicht meine Lieblingsfarbe aber
irgendwie hat's was feste Dusche für
Haare Körper mit fapackung zum Reisen
ah ach so 40 Mal kann man mit dem
duschbrocken Duschen und es ist für
Haare und Körper x skincare kannst du
dieses Video stitchen und deine Reaktion
darauf bringen nee also ja ich habe das
Gefühl Timo würde ich das sofort geben
und ich glaube der würde damit super
duschen können ich kann mir nur nicht
vorstellen dass meine Haare und mein
Körper einfach von der gleichen Seife
gewaschen werden aber ich habe es
tatsächlich auch noch nicht wirklich mal
ausprobiert deswegen vielleicht probiere
ich das mal Nummer Z merkt ihr es
Geschenk auspacken handgemachte
Schokolade mit nachhaltigem Kakao und
winterlichen würzen ich darf Dich gar
nicht essen ich würde schon probieren
wollen aber die hat ganz schön viel
Zucker die gebe ich euch uh aber es sind
Schokolade mit Zimt naken Kardamon ingwa
Vanille die schokoladigen Leckereien von
lamara gehören zu den besten
veganüßigkeiten die wir jemals gegessen
haben ach komm komm das muss ich wissen
die jinglebs Schokolade
hübsch hier auch WoW irgendwie ist
dieses Plastik sehr intens und es fällt
in diesem nachhaltigen Kalender auf
nicht nur weil Plastik aber weil
so Plastik Plastik ist vegane
Schokolade Alter ist die
würzig ist extrem
lecker voll salzig diese Schokolade
schmeckt sehr gut ne schmeckt wirklich
sehr gut habe ich noch nie von gehört
von der Marke Leute die Schokolade kommt
aus Barbing wer ist aus Barbing schreibt
in die Kommentare e Barbing was geht ab
oder Nummer D ich habe zu viel augenm-up
zum heulen aber meistens kommen die
Rentner die mich wirklich zum Heulen
bringen die kommen immer zum Schluss ein
Jahr ein sicheres zuuhause für 27 Kinder
und Jugendliche ein Dach über den Kopf
und ein warmes Bett fließend Wasser
genug zu essen oder auch Zugang zu
Internet und Bildung was für uns ganz
alltäglich klingt sind Privilegien die
nicht alle allen zur Verfügung stehen
und vor allem auch eine liebende
beschützende Familie zu haben kega door
of Hope die adventsomspende über 100000
€ deckt die laufenden Hauskosten für
Lebens und Reinigungsmittel Strom Gas
Telefon
kommunalgebühren kleine regelmäßige
Reparaturen und mehr für ein ganzes Jahr
sehr schön und das ist halt das tolle an
diesem Kalender ne
man Nummer vier ist groß na toll das
kann ich nicht
trinken Kaffee impact coffee schlürfen
for a better world kräftiger
schokoladiger specialty coffee mit
nachhaltigen impact plastic to beans
setzen sich für den Aufbau von
Kunststoff Recycling in Äthiopien ein
und haben sogar ein Gesetz dort
beeinflusst #chlffenfeuer butterworld
ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür wie du
auch mit kleinen Entscheidungen wie der
Wahl deines morgentlichen Kaffees impact
kreieren kannst also Timo wird sich
freuen schokoladeekaramel wenn
Kaffeebohnen
schokoladeekaramel Geschmack haben ist
das dann einfach der Geschmack der
Röstung oder wird da irgendwie Geschmack
hinzugefügt ich kenne mich leider nicht
so aus cool Nummer 5 als wir bei der
Jeremy fragrance Premiere waren gab es
die auch aber die war nicht vegan da war
immer Sahne drin dunkle Schokolade Zimt
diese knalle Popcorn finde ich ja cool
ne und die schmecken auch wirklich sehr
gut aber was mich jedes Mal wieder
schockiert ist der Preis so sieht das
Popcorn aus ich liebe es wenn ich euch
solche Sachen swatche das ist so wie
Beauty Youtuber früher hallo meine
Lieben also das ist der
Popcorn oh mein Gott ist das lecker wie
schafft man das das Popcorn so kugelig
aufspringen sonst sieht der Popcorn
anders aus so in alle 38 oder so kostet
so eine Packung ne Nikolaus oh mein Gott
das macht so Sinn Socken an Nikolaus
Socken gibt's jedes Jahr und jedes Jahr
von jungfield glaube ich glaub die
Socken sind auch jedes Jahr
drin oh mein Gott das ist ein tolles
Design die finde ich sehr hübsch ich
weiß nicht warum wo wird das hergestellt
fapuzierte Socken aus Biobaumwolle die
stinken auf jeden Fall nicht die riechen
sehr gut kein chemischer Duft und sehr
schön weich von
innen Nummer
7 cheesisch vegane Alternative zu Käse
eine Käsealternative Maismehl Zwiebeln
Salz hilfeextrakt undum okay die Liste
sieht nicht so lang aus Parmesan soll
das
sein tüchchen
Nummer
purpum für gestraffte und pralle Haut
okay ich zieh jetzt mal meine Socken war
schön warm da drunter mal pler purple W
schon dass schwarzer Trüffel auch
natürlich ein Botox genannt wird er
schmeichelt nämlich nicht nur g sondern
unsere Haut underneuerung schwarzer
Trüffel auf die Haut ich glaube die
Marke war letztes Jahr auch schon drin
irgendwie habe ich Flashbacks nee
skincare bitte mal Stellung beziehen ein
Baum für jedes bestellte Produkt das ist
doch mal was das ist vielleicht
interessant für skincare ich weiß nicht
ob es gut ist Trüffel ins Gesicht zu
schmieren aber das verlose ich natürlich
an euch dann könnt ihr das herausfinden
und mir schreiben okay Plans purple was
kostet denn so ein Serum
44,50 wow meistens steht dermatologisch
getestet die haben sogar ihr Zertifikat
da drin jetzt ist aber Zeit für Nummer
ne wir nehmen das Business hier sehr
ernst Nummer 9 bestes Türchen wer sich
jetzt fragt warum es ist meine
Lieblingszahl Magnethalter für Seifen
und Koh 100% für dich 110% für den
planetenorrow SP das ist jetzt aber
nicht das beste Türchen das ist wie bei
meiner Oma die hat auch immer
so ja natürlich ist das nachhaltig e
absolut ne wenn man halt feste Seife
benutzt ah ja okay also man hat das und
dann steckt man das so ganz fest in die
Seife rein und dann kann man sie so ran
bapsen und dann nimmt man sie und wäscht
seine Hände und dann BST man sie wieder
ran ja nee das ist das Prinzip ja gut ja
das ist jetzt kein Produkt was mich aus
den Socken haut bin ich ehrlich aber nee
es haut mich nicht aus den Socken ich
dabei Nummer 10 das ist wieder Zeit für
unseren Brief wir haben einen Brief
gekriegt wir haben einen Brief gekriegt
ich frag mich nur von wem anyway made
with love in Köln Mentoring Programm und
Weihnachtsfeier für Quere Jugendliche
unser Jugendzentrum dessen Angebot sich
speziell an lesbische und schwule sowie
bisexuelle und Trans interter und Quere
lsbtiq Menschen zwischen 14 und 27
Jahren richtet liegt mitten in Köln
einer an sich sehr toleranten Stadt
dennoch zeigt unsere Arbeit viel viele
unserer BesucherInnen kämpfen mit Angst
Einsamkeit und diskriinierung die
adventsumpende setzen wir ein um die
Kosten für dieses Mentoring Programm ein
Jahr lang zu decken außerdem möchten wir
an den Weihnachtsfeiertagen das anyway
für die jungen LSBTI
IQ plus öffnen für die die Adventszeit
schwierig ist und ihn eine Familie sein
mit Ihnen feiern und festlich schlemmen
oh mein Gott ist das süß ohne
Diskriminierung wäre sowas gar nicht
nötig aber toll dass es das gibt Nummer
11 ich will das ja wirklich gar nicht
essen ne ich muss das halt aus
wissenschaftlichen Gründen das tut mir
extrem Leid oh was ein salziger
karamellkern war mal die war letztes
Jahr auch schon
[Musik]
dabei sehr dattelig man schmeckt immer
wenn Sachen mit Datteln gesüßt sind es
sind biodattelkugeln also wer sollten
Sie schmecken dieses Ding ist wirklich
köstlich oh mein Gott
oh so viel zu viel Zucker Datteln Dattel
Sirup kokosblütenzucker seit pamill reif
wissen wir das ist einfach normaler
Zucker
reissiruppulver Reissirup wow okay es
hat zwar viel Zucker aber ganz ehrlich
nur weil du vegan bist heißt es ja nicht
dass du auch nicht mal richtig naschen
kannst und für naschen naschen schmeckt
das richtig gut und nicht nur für
Veganer sondern auch für mich Laktose
unverträglichen ist das halt extrem
lecker das ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker
bisschen sehr dattelig aber lecker
Halbzeit Nummer 12 wir öffnen unser
Geschenk what das ist ja ein ganz
kleines Startup was man ja überhaupt
nicht kennt Ava und may die AdV
oh das ist das was hier so krank riecht
e aber und Merzen Geistes krank teuer
handgemachte Duftkerze in adventom
Edition die sind mit sojawachs das hier
soll nach Rose Himbeere und
Champagner riechen i mean yes ich frage
mich nur wo ich diesen Duft haben wollen
würde der ist halt süßlich und ich bin
nicht so der süß Fan sehr süßer Duft
aber mega cool dass sie eine eigene
Edition haben aber und may also wir
haben unseren Preis schon wieder drin
die Leute die sich gerade beschweren und
denken ich will dass du die Preise
nachrechnest nee bei diesem Kalender
möchte ich nicht die Preise nachrechnen
ich finde das so gut gemacht und da
geht's wirklich nicht darum wie viel
konnte man einsparen ich finde die
Auswahl schön ich finde die Türchen
machen Spaß besonders der
seifenmagnethalter und deswegen will ich
einfach nur mal genießen und jetzt
genießen wir die Nummer 13
yay Beat Jerky Beef Jerky für Veganer
Beef Jerky oh das gefällt mir gut rote
Bee sehr gesund bildet dein Blut und ist
gesund luftgetrocknete rote bet slies in
leckerer Marinade ohne Zuckerzusatz
glutenfrei Proteinquelle aber hat von
Natur aus 35 g Zucker ich habe schon mal
Beef Jerky probiert ich find es aber ein
bisschen ich fin es
crazy das hat wirklich diesen Beef Jerky
Vibe
umfast die Konsistenz man muss rote Bee
mögen um das zu
essen es tut mir leid ich fand die Idee
mega gut aber es ist viel zu
salzig ich weiß nicht wie viel Sojasoße
die da rein geknallt haben sehr sehr
salzig viele Sachen würde ich gerne
mögen aber das ist bei mir echt
durchgefallen Nummer 14 werden etwas
sein hier glitzert es schon raus war
nicht richtig zu Veganer plastikfreier
bi
Glitzer nein scheiße ich bin jetzt voler
Glitzer Veganer plastikfreier bioglitzer
für die Haut oder zum
spannend auf jeden Fall der legt sich
auch so voll auf die Haut drauf ich
meine ist ja nicht so dass ich Glitzer
nicht mag ne kommt ich habe Bock
limitierte feste Handcreme mit
Tannenduft zum Nachfüllen for people who
care der Handpflege daumschmaus fing
alles an als Kletterlehrer in Köln
strapazierte Beno seine Hände sein
wichtigstes Werkzeug täglich weswegen er
besondere Pflege gebraucht hat also
festes Duschgel und sowas das Ken
mittlerweile aber
Handcreme ja das ist irgendwie nasty wie
ein Yogastudio ganz toll mag ich diesen
Duft wenn ihr noch nie in einem
Yogastudio wart dann ist es natürlich
jetzt schwer nachzuvollziehen kleine
Challenge an euch geht mal in ein
Yogastudio aber es hat doch eine Alu
Verpackung ich kenne mich mit Verpackung
zu wenig aus aber Alu ist vielleicht
einfacher zu recycle die Dose mehrfach
verwenden mit unserem Nachfüller dann
kauft man sich nur den Nachfüller und
dann hat man sein handcremedose okay ich
mag den Duft ich mag den Duft richtig
gerne das ist genau dieser Yoga Studio
Duft den ich am liebsten tragen würde
daumenschmaus ihr seid klasse die gebe
ich nicht an euch ich meine ich habe sie
schon in meinen Händen gerieben deswegen
sollte ich sie eh nicht an euch
weitergeben aber die behalte ich Nummer
16 ich könnte mal wieder ein Snack
vertragen ja ihr dachtet golden milk
kann man nur trinken tja jetzt gibt's
auch den Riegel und ihr könnt es Essen
bioenergieriegel mit
gerösteter Gerste für lang anhaltende
Power geil ich will gleich joggen gehen
deswegen passt das perfekt
ballerstoffreich ohne Zusätze clean
eating Energieriegel oh no das ist
wirklich wie viel kurkuma ist denn da
drin 1,5% Kurkuma ja da muss man
aufpassen das ist
Kurkuma oh no ist mir ins Glitzer
gefallen das Glitzer ist ja plastikfrei
gell schmeckt wie süßer Hafer das sch
süre ist okay schmeckt nicht schlecht ne
schmeckt sogar richtig gut weg vom
futtern wir haben einen Brief bekommen
wir haben schon wieder ein Gruppenfoto
eine behinderteneng gerechte volier für
unsere gefiederten Schützlinge Kölner
Tauben hilfeev gescheucht getreten
verjagt Stadttauben haben es nicht
deicht mit der adventsumspende über
10000 € haben wir eine Voliere für die
hilfsbedürftigsten Tauben gebaut in
einem kleinen Wohnwagen und einer
angrenzenden Terrasse finden die Blinden
einbeinigen oder flugunfähigen Tauben
ein dauerhaftes gemütliches Zuhause
welches Ihren Bedürfnissen entsprechend
eingerichtet ist und in Schutz bietet
also wirklich eine behindertenengerechte
Voliere für die Tauben ich bin aber
mittlerweile auch auf diesem Tripp ich
finde Tauben gar nicht so scheiße ich
hatte immer das Vorurteil dass die halt
super dreckig sind sind halt die Ratten
der Lüfte aber selbst ratten sind ja ja
komm ich will diese fast gar nicht
aufmachen schöne Spende Nummer 18 boah
das ist ein
Riesenteil
okay
99,9% Bio Aloe Vera Direktsaft für mehr
Wohlbefinden und Vitalität schenke dir
selbst eine Umarmung von innen mit dem
Bio alo V wild bamboon den einzigen Aloe
veraaft den ich probiert habe ist der
den ihr wahrscheinlich auch kennt diese
Plastikflasche mit diesen Stückchen da
drin g ich krieg es nicht auf ich habe
doch gerade Energieriegel gegessen wie
geht das denn
jetzt ja na ja kann ich nichts dazu
sagen ist bestimmt sehr gut weiter
geht's kann ich nicht öffnen
19 ja Timo komm mal her kannst du mir
mal versuchen die Ben und Anna
erfrischende Zahnpasta in recyclebarer
Tube cool Coco Mania die Frage ist jetzt
ist sie bunt ne die sieht aus wie
Kokosöl ich Brau ich Brau D ich brauch
dich ich bin bei Türchen Nummer 19 du
musst diese Flasche öffnen kannst du vor
der Kamera tun damit du zeigst wie
schwer es ist also so deine ja äh
ja vielen Dank das schwer war das schwer
mein Freund ist so
stark das schmeckt
ekelhaft so stelle ich mir Brottrunk vor
ja Nachgeschmack auch furchtbar also das
schmeckt so als ob es gesund sein muss
ich sag's euch ehrlich das kann nicht
nicht gesund sein ich versuch's mal
Krieg mal jetzt ein paar schots so
morgens ich sag euch ob ich mich besser
fühle sehr gesund vielen Dank jetzt
zurück zur Zahnpasta ist es einfach nur
Kokos es gibt Leute die Spülen mit
Kokosfett einfach nur ihren Mund jeden
Morgen aus was super sein soll gegen
Bakterien und so ich glaub soll die
Zähne weißer machen die neue Zahnpasta
enthält natürliches Natriumchlorid das
den Zahnschmelz stärkt und kommt in
einer unendlich oft recyclebaren Tube
aus der du durch Alu aufrollen
den letzten Rest easy rausbekommst diese
Tuben sind gut zum recycen hübsch sieht
sie auf jeden Fall aus besser als meine
Standard Tube die ich nehmen in der
20 wird doch wieder gesnackt organic
manok Chips Weegen Bacon Flav ich glaube
bin mir ziemlich sicher dass aus der
manjokwurzel auch Fufu gemacht wird
oder manwurzel findet man eigentlich
immer in asier Läden das schmeckt
richtig gut gut aber hat halt auch viel
Fett ne 21 ach oh wie süß ein kleines
Puzzle mit Christmas hege also solche
Christmas Motive ne ja Gewinn mein Herz
ein Mini Puzzle mit 99 Teilen ja guck
mal da kann man mal wenigstens einmal
puzzeln und das auch fertig machen ich
liebe diese Taus Teile Puzzle von
rabensburger aber es dauert halt echt
Wochen bei uns und dann hat man
irgendwann keine Zeit mehr und dann
liegt es darum will man es nicht
einpacken weil man schon so weit
gekommen ist und am Ende liegt bei uns
auf unserem Esstisch zwei Monate lang im
PZ da so 99 Teile puusseln natürlich gut
und gerade so als Türchen um es einfach
an dem Tag dann zu machen cute 22
frittensoße vegane pommessoße also ja es
ist ganz witzig ich muss aber sagen zur
Weihnachtszeit denke ich jetzt nicht so
unbedingt an Fritten vor allem weil man
ja zu Hause eher selten Pommes ist ja
gut alle haben jetzt Airfryer und da
machen Sie sich wahrscheinlich öfter
Pommes aber ich bin jetzt z.B jemand der
ist zu Hause nie Pommes wenn ich mir
eine Pommes hole dann unterwegs ja
frittensoße das vorletzte Türchen ich
ich habe gerade das gesehen und dachte
da ist eine CD drin me myself and I
Augenpads 30 mal wieder verwendbar
wieder verwendbare Augenpads mit
Hyaluron ab nach einer durchfeierten
Nacht einem langen Arbeitstag oder
einfach so wir sind große Fans von
Augenpads und dem tollen Effekt direkt
nach der Anwendung frischer auszusehen
und sich entspannter zu fühlen das
stimmt Augenpads aber bei mir ist
irgendwie so ein Lifestyle Ding also ich
mag Augenpads weil das Gefühl von
Augenpads mag 30 mal wieder verwendbar
und deutlich günstiger als wegwerfpads
benutzen packt man sie wieder in die
Dings und dann denkst aber ist das
haluron dann die ganze Zeit da drin habe
ich noch nie von gehört 30 Mal reusable
ist aber auch schön kurz vor Weihnachten
dann kann man richtig frisch und schön
glänzen wie wie der Tannenbaum wir
kommen zum 24 Türchen es ist Weihnachten
und sicher werden wir reichlich
beschenkt deswegen gibt's dieses Mal
etwas für
andere mit schwerer lungentzündung und
drei Katzen im Gepäck aber ohne
Krankenversicherung Dach über dem Kopf
oder geldand im Januar ein Pärchen vor
unserer Tür und fragte uns nach
Schlafsäcken da keine Notunterkunft sie
mit Tieren Aufnahmen so geht es vielen
Obdachlosen Menschen lieber übernachten
Sie frierend und krank auf der Straße
als sich von ihrem vierfürtigen
Begleiterin zu trennen unser Kaffee mit
Herz versteht sich seit über 20 Jahren
als San paulis sozialer Hafen hier
erhalten unsere täglich ca 300 Besucher
in lebensmittelkleidung Zugang zu
duschen und Frischwasser so wie immer
ein offenes Ohr medizinische Versorgung
insbesondere Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe ja
das braucht es mehr ne Orte wo sie sich
zurückziehen können und wo sie mal
sicher sind für einen Moment und sich
waschen und pflegen können und die Tiere
dabei haben das ist extrem schön aber
auch alle vier Spenden sind sehr wichtig
und immer ein tolles Zeichen finde ich
in diesem Adventskalender also da wird
man einfach alle paar Tage wieder dran
erinnert dass es Menschen gibt die Hilfe
brauchen die es nicht so leicht haben
wie man selbst oder z.B Tiere ja da tut
man einerseits was Gutes wenn man diesen
Kalender kauft und andererseits tut
diese Spende ja einem selber auch was
Gutes und man hat ein gutes Gefühl es
schenkt einem einfach ein gutes Gefühl
die Produkte waren dieses Mal wieder
sehr umfangreich mein
magnetseifen
spend werde ich in Herzen halten ich bin
Fan ich bin Fan von diesem
Adventskalender also wenn ich mir einen
wünschen würde dann wäre auf jeden Fall
adventor mit auf der Liste weil die
Produkte sind einfach so schön
umfangreich man hat bei den meisten
Produkten auch ein gutes Gefühl weil es
einfach nachhaltig ist und einfach auch
was Neues zum Entdecken also ich kannte
jetzt die meisten Sachen hier nicht und
das ist schon mal cool weil da kann man
was entdecken ne ich pfeif mir jetzt
noch diese daffel hier rein ich sag's
euch wie es
ist H